Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. The truth is, no one does it alone. And why would you want to? We all need someone to make us believe. And why would you want to? We all need someone to make us believe. Hashtag, you got this. The Norman Conquest is the great turning point in the history of the English nation. Since the first settlement of the English in Britain, the introduction of Christianity is the only event which can compare with it in importance.
And there is this wide difference between the two. The introduction of Christianity was an event which could hardly fail to happen sooner or later. In accepting the Gospel, the English only followed the same law which sooner or later affected all the Teutonic nations. But the Norman conquest is something which stands without a parallel in any other Teutonic land. If that conquest be only looked on in its true light, it is impossible to exaggerate its importance. And yet, there is no event whose true nature has been more commonly and more utterly mistaken. So that was Edward Augustus Freeman, who
is the Regus Professor of History at Oxford University. And this is the opening of his gargantuan six volume history of the Norman conquest, which was commissioned to mark its 800th anniversary, the 800th anniversary of the Battle of Hastings. And it was published, it took him 13 years to publish it between 1867 and 1879 and Tom finally in the rest is history we come to the greatest narrative of English history and at its center is the most famous year in our history it's the astonishingly thrilling and unpredictable events of 1066. Yes. A year, as you said, of unbelievable drama. And as Edward Augustus Freeman said, a year that is perhaps the decisive
dividing line in English history. And the drama revolves, I suppose, at its most basic around three men, doesn't it? Yeah. So you have the King of England who comes to the throne on the 5th of January, 1066, Harold Godwinson. And over the course of 1066, he fights two great battles against invaders who are aiming to topple him from his throne. And the first of these invaders, Harold Hardrada, the hard ruler,
the King of Norway, he fails in his attempt, but the second invaders, Harold Hardrada, the hard ruler, the king of Norway. He fails in his attempt, but the second invader, William, the Duke of Normandy succeeds and Harold perishes in this great battle fought outside Hastings. I would say the most decisive battle in not just English, but British history. Yeah. He is then crowned King on Christmas day in 1066 and he establishes Norman rule permanently over a conquered people. So Tom, we're going to get into this story in tremendous and thrilling detail in the weeks that follow.
But first of all, you said British history. So obviously this happens in England, but it's enormously significant for in the long run for Wales and for Scotland, but also for Ireland too. Am I right? Absolutely, because Norman rule ends up being established over all those parts of the British Isles. And I would say that the impact of the battle of Hastings and the Norman conquest reverberates far beyond our islands to go all Churchillian. Yeah, because we have a lot of overseas listeners in Australia, in the United States, whatever. And they might be saying, well, you know, who cares who rules England? Why is that a big deal for me? I mean, the answer is given as a joke in probably the most famous comic version of English history ever
written, 1066 and all that, and the title is very striking. I mean, the assumption that 1066 is what English history is all about. So it's written in 1930 when the British Empire was still very much a going concern. And the authors of that book are trying to explain why the Norman conquest matters. And they say the Norman conquest was a good thing as from this time onwards England stopped being conquered and thus was able to become top nation which is a joke of course but it hints at the long-term significance of 1066 because the people the country that is forged as a result of the normal conquest those people in due course will go on to settle North America, to rule the largest global empire the world has ever seen, to settle entire continents.
And I mean, just to focus on one obvious way in which the Norman conquest impacts not just England, but the whole world, is the fact that English, the language of England, is now the world's global lingua franca as a result of the centuries that follow the Norman conquest. And that's why people in Australia or New Zealand or America will be listening to this and understanding it. And the language that we are speaking is one that bears massive witness to the fusion of old English and French.
And not just that, but also the, the but also the Norse element too, right? All those three people, Harold Hodrada, Harold Goldwincent and William of Normandy are all reflected in the words we're using. Absolutely. So that's why I think that this reverberates far beyond this kind of what, I mean, let's be honest, in the 11th century is a fairly unimportant kind of corner of the Eurasian landmass. I mean, it's not of corner of the Eurasian landmass. I mean, it's not even part of the Eurasian landmass. He hates Britain. I mean, that is shocking.
I don't because as I've been saying, you know, great things await. But I do think that this is a story that really matters. And it's a story that like the French Revolution, we know we did one episode on the French Revolution, we've expanded it. We also did one episode on 1066 early in this podcast, and we're going to expand on that. I mean, not quite to the length of the French Revolution. What it has in common with the French Revolution or with, I don't know, a TV series like Game of Thrones, say, with which it might be compared, is it's a thrilling soap opera. There are all kinds of twists and turns in the narrative. There's all kinds of courage and duplicity and treachery and, you know, extraordinary acts of bravery and resistance and whatnot. But at the center of it are these three fantastic characters and they're all three are warlords and
each of them stands for I guess in the public imagination a wider kind of civilization I guess so the Saxons, the Norse and the Normans. Yeah so Harold is often called the last English king, I mean, whether he is, we'll look at in due course, but he's indisputably the king of a very distinctive, sophisticated and ultimately doomed kind of civilization, that of Anglo-Saxon England. Harold Hardrada, probably the most famous warrior of his day, is likewise the kind of the last embodiment of an order that is starting to fade and that's the Viking world. And William, the Duke of Normandy, he himself has Viking ancestry, but he's also the embodiment of a kind of great revolution in the affairs
of Christendom, probably Europe's first. And in that sense, he is the face of the future. Far bit for me to disagree with Regent's Professor of History at Oxford, but I think Freeman is wrong in saying that England would have carried on as it had done had the Norman Conquest not happened, because I think actually, as we will see, this revolution that William embodies is so profound and overwhelming that it would have transformed England and Britain more generally no matter what. So at the heart of this is the prize right like the Iron Throne and Game of Thrones the prize is England and you mentioned oh who should care about England it's on the edge of Eurasia or all this kind of thing but actually the really important thing that listeners should get into
their heads is that England is such a prize Because it's an incredibly precocious nation state that is peaceful well run and crucially Rich that's what makes it so tempting for overseas predators. Yes, it's like You know walking down muggersey with a large diamond necklace sticking out of your back pocket. England is by far the wealthiest and best governed realm in Northern Europe in the 11th century. And I mean, it's not up there with say the Byzantine Empire or Al-Andalus, the great Muslim caliphate in Spain. But definitely compared to the empire that Charlemagne had ruled, for instance,
the great empire of the Franks or let alone the kingdoms of Ireland or Scotland or of Scandinavia. It is remarkably centralised, it is remarkably urbanised and it is incredibly rich. And that is what makes it the great prize. So I guess the first question is why is England so exceptional in the kingdoms of Europe? So when the Franks are all fighting each other and divided and whatnot and when Germany, what becomes Germany is obviously you know so divided. Why is England exceptional in being so rich, so peaceful, so well organized, so centralized, all of those kinds of things? I think a good way to answer that question is to go back to a scene almost a century
before the Battle of Hastings. And this is the coronation of Edgar in the year 973 in what had been the Roman city of Bath. And Edgar rules as a descendant of a man called Kurdic, who was the legendary founder of a Saxon kingdom in the south of England, the West Saxons, so the kingdom of Wessex. And the line of kings that descend from him all the way down from the first arrival of the Angles and the Saxons in England, all the way down to Edgar in the 10th century, they are called the Kyrgyz-Kingas. And they have an incredible prestige because most, mainly of all, Edgar is the descendant, not just of Kurdic, but of Alfred the Great.
Very much a friend of the show. I'd say a hero of the show. So he's the guy who had saved Wessex from the Danes, from the pagans in the middle of the ninth century, in the late ninth century. And he had begun the process. I mean, he hadn't completed it, but he had begun the process of welding together all the different Anglo-Saxon kingdoms, hadn't he? And he'd put, he'd invested in towns, in fortifying the towns and all of these kinds of things.
Yeah, so burrs, which are not just fortified, but also stimulate trades to therefore to make England rich. And he had not only flung the Danes, the Northmen, the Wikingas, as the English call them robbers or Vikings, out of Wessex, but also out of a large chunk of Mercia, which is the kingdom to the north, so in what is now the Midlands of England. And he had done this in a way that the Mercians are kind of under his authority, but they don't feel like a conquered people. And the genius of Alfred is to promote the idea that the Saxons, the people that he rules, and the Angles, the Mercians, the people of East Anglia and Northumbria further north, that these
are a kind of single people. So Alfred rules as the Rex Angle Saxon and the king of the Anglo-Saxons. And this process of absorbing the various English speaking peoples of Britain, peoples who before the coming of the Vikings had lived in separate kingdoms. This continues under his son, Edward, and his daughter Athelflad and under his grandson Athelstan. And it is Athelstan who completes the creation of effectively a United Kingdom of England. Yeah, Inglaland, they call it, don't they? Inglaland, the land of the Angles, and both the Saxons and the Angles start to call themselves the Anglekin, which I think you can legitimately start to call the English by this period.
So Edgar is Athelstan's nephew. Yes. So when Edgar is crowned in Bath, he is becoming king of something that lots of historians actually now say is one of Europe's very first, one of the world's very first nation states. People who think they're all part of one big national family, the Anglican, the English, and this is England. And one of the things that defines it is law and order. You pay your taxes. There's a state. You know, this is how it works. It's not anarchy. It's centralized. This is how it works. Yes. So to quote James Campbell, who's the historian of this process, who is best associated with the idea that this United Kingdom of England is a nation-state.
He says of it, the creation of the English state was perhaps the most remarkable and certainly the most lasting feat of statecraft in 10th century Europe. And in a way, the coronation of Edgar at Bath, and it's the second of his reign, he's already had one, but now he wants to kind of really emphasize the degree to which he's a kind of imperial figure. This is why he's having himself crowned amid the Roman ruins of Bath. But he also has himself anointed as the kings of Israel had done. So he's casting himself as an English king.
And of course, as Charlemagne, the great Frankish emperor who'd been crowned in Rome had done. So Edgar is also kind of laying claim to that tradition. Yeah. And of course, as listeners in Scotland and Wales will know, this isn't necessarily good news for the princes of Wales or Scotland. Uh, and in fact, Edgar's next stunt after his coronation in Bath is to have himself rode down the river D, uh, by various kinds of princelings that he summoned Welsh princelings. I think that's completely reasonable.
I have to say for the people who wonder how the rest of this history works, I will just say that while Tom has been talking about the unique, exceptional wealth centralization, sophistication of England, he's actually been trolled by our producer Theo, who's writing in the chat, looking forward to the French invasion, which is poor from you, Theo. Well, is it French? I mean, this is this is something that we will be discussing. So Theo is trying to throw Tom off piste.
I know he won't because I know Tom, you want to talk about Edgar. Now Edgar is always known as Edgar the peaceable, which makes him sound like a lovely, he's a lovely guy, likes flower ranging and watercolors. But in reality, people call him Edgar the peaceable because if you step out of line, he will probably blind and scalp you. Is that right? Yes, he absolutely will. And he will inflict punishment on entire counties. So in 969, some merchants from York are kidnapped by robbers in Kent. And Egger's response to this
is to ravage the entire county. And ravaging is going to be a theme of this series. And it essentially means you lay waste to everything. Yeah. I think people generally like ravaging in history podcasts. So time will tell. And Dominic, they like Law and Order, don't they? They do. Both.
And I really, I like Law and Order a lot. So Edgar's your kind of guy. He's absolutely the kind of guy that in my previous incarnation as a newspaper columnist, I would have very much applauded. You'd been all over him. Yeah. I'd have been all over him like a rash. Sensi of policies for a happier Ingliland. Yeah.
So that's one aspect of Edgar's reign, but the other, you talked about the internal stability. I mean, it's tribute to the remarkable feat of Alfred and his heirs that they have been able to foster a kind of unitary national identity that is shared by peoples of the formerly independent kingdoms of Wessex, East Anglia, Mercia, Northumbria. And the way in which the Kurdic ingas, the kings who descend from the line of Kurdic have been able to do that is because they have as partners in their great project, a unitary church. So you can have Northumbrian saints being celebrated in Wessex and vice versa. You have kind of
a common language, they're very kind of strong regional variants, but essentially people can kind of understand, you know, if you're from Devon, you can probably just about understand someone from Northumbria. And perhaps most crucially of all, there is a single currency. So there is a kingdom wide uniformity of design and these coins are under the firm control of royal moneyers. So no one else is allowed to mint coins and it issues a formal decree. One coinage should be current throughout all the king's realm and no one shall refuse it. And there is a massive contrast here with what is happening on the continent where basically everyone is issuing coins, bishops, princes, dukes, counts, whatever, they're all kind of at it.
So to put Theo back in his box, this is a brilliant example of the contrast between what's happening in England and what is happening in what's now France. On the one hand, you have centralisation, bureaucracy and uniformity, and on the other you have a sort of gibbering chaos, all kinds of nonsense. Yes, exactly. However, however, the great threat to any realm is a succession crisis is the death of a king.
And when Edgar dies, he dies in 975. And so the question is, what's going to happen next? And what is worse, if you're living in the medieval period, the one thing you don't want to see is a comet. Because you know that that brings absolute shambles and disaster. And Edgar dies, they look up, geez, what's a comet blazing overhead? Terrible scenes. What would make people even more nervous is the fact that the throne is claimed by rival
half-brothers. Oh, come on. This is poor. This is terrible. Yeah. So the first of these is a guy called Edward, who is very vicious, kind of very unstable, probably illegitimate, but he is in his teens. The second one is a young boy called Athelred, who is the son of the anointed queen.
So the queen who had sat beside Edgar at the great coronation in Bath. And this is the lady, Alfreda. She's very powerful. She's very ambitious. And so very keen to see her son, Atharad on the throne. But the problem is Atharad is only seven. And the monarchy is elective and the Witan, who is the kind of the assembly of the great men, the great Thanes and the elder men, who are the kind of the assembly of the great men, the great Thanes and the elder men, who are the kind of the guys who rule over the individual counties in England, they meet up and they decide that Edward should become king. The legitimate guy, the teenager.
Yeah, the unstable one. So Alfreda, the queen is very cross and she retires or does she? Because in 978, so that's three years after Edward has ascended to the throne, Alfreda is holidaying near the town of Corth on the Dorset coast in the south of England and Edward goes hunting near there and he's riding through the forest, kind of blowing on his horn, and suddenly a group of armed men step out of the undergrowth, confront him, surround him. They seize him by his right arm, they break it. Another guy pulls out a dagger, stabs it into the side of the king. Edward,
by this point, dying. His horse goes galloping away, his foot gets caught in the stirrup, he's kind of dragged, his head head smashing on rocks as he goes along dragged away through brambles and undergrowth and The assassins follow him get hold of his corpse and throw it into a bog So now this means that the other bloke Ethel Red Ready or not is going to become a king, but he's only 10 and what's worse, they're consecrating him as king and it's at this point that people see a bloody cloud. I mean that's literally what they call it, a bloody cloud.
So this is in the Anglo-Saxon Chronicles, it must be true. It must be true, many times in the likeness of flames and it appeared most of all at midnight and it was formed of various beams. And then when it became day, it glided away. I mean, that's a terrible portent, isn't it? But the amazing thing is, despite this, the kingdom does not fall to pieces. And actually, the fact that Edward's murder is seen as something utterly shocking, which it is, is kind of evidence, I think, of just how habituated people in England by this point had become to the rule of the law. In fact, James Campbell points out that Edward was
the first man of high blood to have perished as a result of civil strife among the English for more than 50 years. So that's a very, very kind of striking statistic. Yeah. And Arthur Redd, even though he's 10, he has lots of good people and indeed a very effective woman behind him. So Alfreda, his mother, she's very, very shrewd political operator, whether she was behind the murder or not, very much up for grabs. She's on holiday there by coincidence.
Who knows? But definitely she plays a good hand. So she makes sure that Edward's followers are given their share of kind of honors and all that kind of stuff. Edward's own body is treated with great respect. It's pulled out of the bog, put in a tomb, and visitors to the tomb start to report incredible miracles, and to do course Edward will come to be known as Edward the Martyr. And Athelred, as the only surviving male member of the Curda Kinggz, descendant of Alfred the Great, he can command the loyalty of the great men of the kingdom. And he is raised by his advisors, by his mother, to respect his heritage and to appreciate
all the resources that he can command as the King of England. So a big spoiler alert, he ends up having a very, very bad reputation as a King of England and some scholars think this is incredibly unfair. And actually in your notes, you give an example of how he's wielding the machinery of government in a very effective and competent and well thought out way. So you mentioned the coins. Yeah. So they will the coins. Yeah. So they will recall all the silver coins and they will restamp them. And then he will take a cut and they will reissue them.
And this is basically to, to maintain the integrity of the coinage and to eliminate forgery and fakes and also to back up the, the Royal treasuries. Cause he's always taking a cut. And this is the kind of thing you can only do if you are running a really really well-oiled you know well organized machine and you can do this in maybe the Eastern Roman Empire and Constantinople or you can do it in you know the Caliphate or in Cordoba or whatever but you can't do it in a shambolic divided realm like that of the Franks where they're all just stabbing each other in the back and it's all very chaotic.
So what Edgar and now Athelred in turn are finessing is a kind of very, very sophisticated apparatus of state intrusion. So there were officials who know how much land a certain person may give and therefore how much money they should be paying. And this ability of the English kings to raise cash is a crucial part of what makes England so rich and will be a very important part of this story. And under Arthur Redd, England becomes steadily ever more prosperous. So the towns that Alfred had founded, the Burs, you know, they're flourishing markets are full of traders from across Northern Europe. You have the great men of the kingdom, the elder men, the Thanes, you know, they're kind of lavishing gold and incense and silks on their local
churches and on themselves. And Athol Redd's own treasure chests are starting to fill to overflowing. But here you have the problem, right? Because we've been describing the victim as it were of this crime. If it is a crime, the prize, which is England, but it's from this point, the reign of Ethelred that people overseas start looking at all this and saying, Oh, England, very peaceful. You know, so they obviously are not, you know, as accomplished at
fighting as other people, because they're too busy messing around with their coins and thinking about silks. Let's get some of this. Let's have some of this. And this, this starts to become a problem. What about the nine eighties? Yeah. And you have escalating, you must've been always piracy.
There must've been always rate small scale rates that probably don't even show up in the Chronicles. It's from this point that the Danes, for want of a better word, the Vikings come back into the story. Well, you say Danes and they are called Danes, but you know that is a collective group for what we would perhaps call the Vikings. But there is also a particularly predatory Viking who comes from the North Way, what today we would call Norway. And this is a very sinister and charismatic figure called Olaf Trigvason. And I think the fact he comes from the Northway is an important part of his mystique, because even for the Danes, the Northway is seen as a place of wizards and sorcerers and so on.
There must've been always rate small scale rates that probably don't even show up in the Chronicles. It's from this point that the Danes, for want of a better word, the Vikings come back into the story. Well, you say Danes and they are called Danes, but you know that is a collective group for what we would perhaps call the Vikings. But there is also a particularly predatory Viking who comes from the Northway, what today we would call Norway. And this is a very sinister and charismatic figure called Olaf Trigvason. And I think the fact he comes from the Northway is an important part of his mystique, because even for the Danes, the Northway is seen as a place of wizards and sorcerers and so on.
And even the women are meant to have terrifying beards. So it has a certain reputation. And Trigverson himself is a notorious sorcerer and he defines the future by throwing birds bones and kind of reading the way in which they land. And it wins him the very sinister nickname of Cracker Ben or Crowbone. And he is also a very, very effective warrior. In fact,
reportedly he's ambidextrous so he can throw spears with both hands and he is the hero of a kind of myriad gore soaked spray song. And in 991 Trigverson and his fellow freebooters, a kind of great fleet of Vikings are cornered on land at Malden in Essex, so south of East Anglia. And they're confronted by the the elder man of Essex, a guy called Britnorth and the Vikings win, and Britnorth is killed. Do you want to know facts about that, Tom? Yeah, tell me. So obviously, the Battle of Malden is one of the most famous old English poems.
But you know, he was obsessed with the Battle of Malden, JRR Tolkien. And the stands that Beardnot makes at the Battle of Malton is apparently the inspiration for the stand that Gandalf makes at the Bridge of Khazad-dum. I did not know that. Isn't that a good fact? I mean, that kind of Tolkien-esque quality of glamour and magic and tragedy does hang over this story. And unsurprisingly, because for Tolkien, the Norman Conquest was
the greatest tragedy in the history of England. And he wanted to write Lord of the Rings to give the English back the mythology that he thought they had lost as a result of the Conquest. Etherred, not a kind of Tolkien-esque hero, really. He decides that the best way to deal with this crisis is to buy the Vikings off off and so he uses his state apparatus to raise ten thousand pounds worth of taxes which inevitably comes to be called the day in gales the gold that is being paid to the day in s and equally inevitably in ninety four for more. And this time, he doesn't just hover the coast, he leads an assault directly on London. It gets beaten back, but he then goes on a kind of great ravaging raid across the heartlands of Wessex. And this, of course, is absolutely an open challenge to Atharad. It's an attempt to shred his authority because Wessex is the heart of the entire English kingdom and the raids just keep coming and coming and
treasure is stripped from churches. Athorettes' subjects are enslaved and this is a hideous experience both for men and women. So, we have an account by a poet who exalts over a rival who had been abducted by slavers and he describes how this rival of his was subjected to insults and urinated upon and then stripped naked forced by the Vikings to perform the sexual service of a wife for women even worse. So we have a bishop who laments the enthusiasm of Vikings for gang rape, the practice of foul sin upon a single woman, the bishop wrote one after another, like dogs that care not about filth. So this is hideous. And it's unsurprising that under their breath, the English begin to
apply a punning title to Athelred. Athelred means well-advised, nobly advised. They start to call him unrad, the badly advised, the ill-advised, which in due course will be anglicized to become. The unready. He wasn't ready. They turned up and he wasn't ready So the thing about him right you could argue he is so hard done by and indeed there are historians like Simon Keynes who say You know actually all that we think about him is just pure propaganda. He's been really really maligned by history
He's not the first person to ever try to pay off Raiders. No Alfred did it Alfred had done it exactly I mean he's paying off. God, I saw an amazing fact. The, the first payment of Dango, which was 10,000 pounds to pay that off. He would have had to have handed over two and a half million individual coins. And Dominic, I know you love a Scandinavian museum. I do. And pretty much every major museum in Denmark or Norway or whatever.
I mean, huge, great piles of silver coins that have come from England. I mean, enormous piles. But you could argue what else can he do? You know, he can't, they don't have coastal defenses of a kind that would protect every last village along the English coast. I mean, you can do your best, but the Danes are mobile. They could strike at any point. Maybe paying them off is actually the more sensible thing.
Well, and also, Althorad has a problem that Alfred did not. And that is the fact that Drighversen and his fellow Vikings, when they plunder their loot or get the Dane Guild or take their slaves, they don't have to sail back directly to Scandinavia because there are welcoming ports and markets much closer to England just across the channel. And these ports and these markets are in a realm so welcoming to the Northmen that it even come to bear their name and this is Normandy Normandy every great drama needs
嗯，而且，阿尔托拉德还有一个阿尔弗雷德没有的问题。那就是德里格弗森（Drighversen）和他的维京同伙们，在他们掠夺战利品、获取丹麦金（Dane Guild）或劫掠奴隶时，并不需要直接航行回斯堪的纳维亚，因为在离英格兰近得多、海峡对岸的地方，就有欢迎他们的港口和市场。这些港口和市场位于一个对北方人极其欢迎的王国，以至于这个王国后来冠上了他们的名字——这就是诺曼底。诺曼底。每一场伟大的戏剧都需要
Terrible villains and finally we come to the villains of this story We will take a break and then we'll return with a man called Rollo. See you in a second take a break and then we'll return with a man called Rollo. See dream, and in it he saw himself placed on a mountain higher than the highest mountain, in a house of a Frankish style. And on the summit of this mountain he saw a spring of sweet smelling water flowing, and he washed himself in it and was cleansed by the water of leprosy. Then around the base of the mountain he saw many thousands of birds of different kinds and various colours, but all with red wings. And these birds went one
可怕的恶棍，最后我们迎来了这个故事中的恶棍。我们先休息一会儿，然后回来介绍一个叫罗洛（Rollo）的人。一会见。休息一下，然后我们回来介绍一个叫罗洛的人。见到了一个梦，在梦中他看到自己置身于一座高于最高山的崇山之上，坐落在一座法兰克风格的房屋里。在这座山的顶峰，他看到一股散发着芬芳的水泉在流淌，他在里面洗澡，麻风病被水清洗干净了。然后，在山脚下，他看到了成千上万只不同种类、色彩各异的鸟，但它们都有红色的翅膀。这些鸟一只接一只地
after the other in perfect harmony to the spring on the mountain, and washed themselves in it. When they had all been anointed by the waters of the spring, the birds all flocked together, as though they were friends sharing food And they carried twigs in their beaks and worked as fast as they could to build nests So that is a lovely story of a dream had by this guy Rollo And it's by a historian who was writing in the time of Ethelred the Unready and was explaining how Normandy this wretched hive of scum and villainy came to be founded. So Tom, before we get into this bonkers dream, Rollo, we call him Rollo or the Normans call
和谐有序地飞向山上的泉水，并在其中沐浴。当它们都被泉水洗礼后，鸟儿们便聚集在一起，就像分享食物的朋友一样。它们的嘴里衔着树枝，以最快的速度筑巢。这就是这个叫罗洛的家伙所做的一个美好的梦的故事。这是一位生活在“无准备者埃塞尔雷德”时期的历史学家写下的，他解释了诺曼底这个充满人渣和恶棍的悲惨蜂巢是如何建立的。所以，汤姆，在我们深入探讨这个疯狂的梦之前，罗洛，我们叫他罗洛，或者诺曼人叫
him Rollo, but I read the other day that back in his native Scandinavia, his name was Ganga Rolf. Yeah. Rolf. Rolf. Yeah. That's the kind of H on the front, doesn't it? Yeah. Like the muppets Ganga Rolf. Yeah. Rolf. Rolf. Yeah. Kind of H on the front, doesn't it? Yeah. Like the muppets Ganga Rolf. Anyway, tell us about Rolf or Rollo. So Rollo Rolf, he was a Viking warlord who with a whole load of other Vikings had occupied the lower reaches of the Sen and they kind of sailed up the Sen and they had basically set about smashing up all the
他罗洛，但我前几天读到，在他的家乡斯堪的纳维亚，他的名字叫甘加·罗尔夫（Ganga Rolf）。是的。罗尔夫。罗尔夫。是的。前面有个“H”的音，对吧？是的。就像布偶剧里的甘加·罗尔夫。是的。罗尔夫。罗尔夫。是的。前面有个“H”的音，对吧？是的。就像布偶剧里的甘加·罗尔夫。不管怎样，给我们讲讲罗尔夫或罗洛吧。所以罗尔夫/罗洛，他是一个维京军阀，曾率领一大批维京人占据了塞纳河下游，他们顺着塞纳河航行，基本上开始摧毁他们发现的所有
props of Frankish power that they discovered. So they'd wiped out all traces of bureaucracy, they had murdered all the local nobility and by about 900, all the region of the Seine estuary had basically become what Frankish chroniclers is called in Veer, which essentially is a place where no one has any authority. It's wasted, it's rubble strewn, the spear alone rules. It's almost a hellish wasteland. And a place without noblemen or churches that you can loot is obviously no good for Vikings. And so Rollo heads south with all the lads looking for better pickings and he gets confronted there by the Frankish King. Charles the Simple.
法兰克权力的支柱。所以他们消灭了所有官僚机构的痕迹，谋杀了所有当地的贵族，到900年左右，塞纳河口的整个地区基本上成了法兰克编年史家所称的“In Veer”（无人区），本质上这是一个没有任何权威的地方。这里一片荒芜，瓦砾遍地，只有长矛说了算。这几乎是一片人间地狱。一个没有贵族或教堂可以洗劫的地方对维京人来说显然毫无用处。于是罗洛带着所有小伙子一路向南寻找更好的猎物，在那里他遇到了法兰克国王——简单王查理。
Charles the Simple, yes. So all the Frankish Kings have mad, mad subrakes. And Charles the Simple, he defeats Rollo, but he doesn't destroy him. And essentially Charles the Simple thinks, well, I think we can come to a deal. This is where in that story that you read, the detail of the sweet spring and Rollo being cleansed of leprosy comes in because the Frankish King makes Rollo an offer. He can have the lands around the Seine, the Enver, the lands that he and the Vikings have devastated, but in return he has to be baptized. He has to accept Christ. And Rollo accepts and in 912 he's baptized by the Bishop of Rouen. So Rouen is very much situated in this kind of dimension of Enver and he's pretty much the only kind of symbol
简单王查理，是的。所以所有的法兰克国王都有疯狂的绰号。而简单王查理击败了罗洛，但他没有消灭他。基本上简单王查理认为，嗯，我觉得我们可以达成一笔交易。这就是你读到的那个故事中，关于甘甜的泉水和罗洛洗净麻风病的细节出现的地方，因为法兰克国王向罗洛提出了一项提议。他可以拥有塞纳河周围的土地，“In Veer”，也就是他和维京人摧毁的土地，但作为交换，他必须接受洗礼。他必须接受基督。而罗洛接受了，于912年由鲁昂主教为他施洗。所以鲁昂非常处于这种“In Veer”的维度中，而且他几乎是唯一一个在维京人的猛烈攻击中幸存下来的法兰克权威象征。你想听一个关于这个仪式的趣事吗？
of Frankish authority that survived the onslaught of the Vikings. Do you want a nice fact about the ceremony? Yeah, go on. They had to queue up to kiss Charles the Simple's foot. Yeah, because he's in his stirrup, isn't he? He's on his horse. And Rollo said, I'm not going to kiss this bloke's foot. And he said in his stead, one of his thugs would do it instead.
好啊，讲讲。他们不得不排队去亲吻简单王查理的脚。对，因为他踩在马镫上，对吧？他骑在马上。而罗洛说：“我才不亲这家伙的脚呢。”他让手下的一个恶棍代劳。
And this bloke went forward to kiss this king's foot. And then he pulled, he jerked the foot up so quickly that Charles the Simple fell off the saddle and fell over backwards and all the Vikings. We had good fooling that day. So, you know, I only told that story because I knew you wouldn't resist the opportunity to do your trademark laugh. Anyway, you'd have heard from me from pointing out that in that story, the waters of the spring are the waters of baptism. So they've now been cleansed.
这个家伙走上前去亲吻国王的脚。然后他猛地一拉，飞快地把脚往上一抬，结果简单王查理从马鞍上摔了下来，来了个四脚朝天，所有的维京人都哈哈大笑。那天我们可真开心。所以呢，我讲这个故事只是因为我知道你无法抗拒展现你标志性笑声的机会。不管怎样，你从我这里听说过，那个故事中泉水的水就是洗礼之水。所以他们现在已经被洗净了。
And what about these nice birds? The birds are immigrants to Rollo's realm. So they are drawn from across the Viking world and actually beyond as well, but they are all warriors. And that's the significance of their red wings. These symbolize the swords dipped in blood. So one people fashioned out of a mixture of different ones. That's how they're described. This is the key thing, right? About the Normans, the thing that people always argue about, are they Northmen, hence the name, or as Theo, a producer would say, and indeed lots of listeners to this podcast would say, actually that Northmen stuff is all just English, sort of the English trying to make excuses, and actually these people are really French.
那么这些漂亮的鸟呢？这些鸟是罗洛领地的移民。所以它们来自整个维京世界，甚至还有之外的地方，但它们全都是战士。这就是它们红色翅膀的意义所在。这些象征着沾满鲜血的剑。一个由不同人群融合而成的单一民族。这就是对它们的描述。这才是关键所在，对吧？关于诺曼人，人们总是争论不休的问题是：他们是北方人（Northmen），因此得名；还是像制片人西奥（Theo）所说，以及本播客的许多听众所说，实际上那些北方人的一切都只是英国人，某种程度上是英国人在找借口，而这些人实际上是真正的法国人？
Well, yes, I mean, it's a fascinating topic and furiously debated, and the answer to that I think evolves over the course of time. So there is no question that a century after Rollo's baptism, this kind of lingering hint of the Viking endures in Normandy. So Rollo himself on his deathbed is supposed to have repented his baptism and to have ordered a hundred Christian captives beheaded before him in honor of his native gods. That's like his last gesture on earth. So basically the baptism thing hasn't entirely worked out well there.
嗯，是的，我的意思是，这是一个迷人且争论激烈的话题，我认为这个答案随着时间的推移而演变。毫无疑问，在罗洛受洗一个世纪后，诺曼底仍然留存着这种挥之不去的维京人气息。据说罗洛本人在临终前曾对自己的洗礼感到后悔，并下令在他面前将一百名基督教俘虏斩首，以向他的本土神明致敬。这就像他在地球上的最后一个举动。所以基本上洗礼这件事在那并没有完全起到预期作用。
His son, the brilliantly named William Longsword, had been a famous patron of these kind of praise singers, these bards who turn up and kind of go on about how brilliant their patron is, how many people they've killed, lots of violence and gloating and bragging and so on. So there's a lot more of that laugh basically in the world of William Longsword. Yes, it's Valkyries weaving tapestries out of the intestines of slaughtered enemies, that kind of thing. That's what's going on. And the son of William Longsword, so Rollo's grandson, a guy called Richard the Fearless, he's a remarkable man. He rules for 54 years
他的儿子，拥有一个绝妙名字的长剑威廉（William Longsword），曾是这些赞美诗歌手（这些四处游走、吹嘘其资助者有多么伟大、杀过多少人、充斥着大量暴力、幸灾乐祸和吹牛的吟游诗人）的著名赞助人。所以在长剑威廉的世界里，基本上还有更多这样的狂野笑声。是的，那是女武神用被屠杀敌人的内脏编织挂毯的场景，就是那种调调。长剑威廉的儿子，也就是罗洛的孙子，一个叫无所畏惧的理查（Richard the Fearless）的家伙，他是一个非凡的人。他统治了54年，
and he's quite old, you know, by the time he dies and in his old age, he comes to resemble Odin, the Allfather, the King of the gods, kind of bright eyed, long bearded. And it was said of him that after dark, he would wander the streets of Rouen cloaked alone and there he would fight with the shades of the dead. And so it's not surprising that he's called by his enemies the Lord of the Vikings, so much so that in 991 when Aethelred has complained to the pope, the pope says, stop hosting Viking ships. And Richard says, okay, yeah, whatever. But he carries on hosting them. And on top of that, his wife is a Dane, meaning that his children are half Danish, and when he dies in 996, his tomb is not in a church but a great earthen mound looking out to sea, so like something out of Beowulf. So it's not surprising that when Athelred gets reports
他去世时已经相当老了，你知道的，而在他的晚年，他开始变得像众神之王、万物之父奥丁——眼神明亮，胡须花白。据说天黑后，他会披着斗篷独自在鲁昂的街头游荡，并在那里与死者的幽灵战斗。所以难怪他的敌人称他为“维京之王”，以至于在991年埃塞尔雷德向教皇抱怨时，教皇说：别再收留维京船只了。而理查说：好吧，随便吧。但他依然继续收留他们。最重要的是，他的妻子是丹麦人，这意味着他的孩子有一半丹麦血统，当他在996年去世时，他的陵墓不在教堂里，而是一个面朝大海的巨大土丘，就像《贝奥武夫》里的场景一样。因此，当埃塞尔雷德得到报告说
that these Viking ships with their English loot and captives are going to Norman ports, he's not surprised in the slightest. This is what he would expect. And yet there is another side to the story, which is that as time has passed, these people have been slowly, dare I say, Frenchified. They've become a little bit more Christian over time, is that fair? And Frankish. So the title that they are given is the Count of Rouen. You know, that's a Latinate title. And again, you can see the way in which even their language is changing by the fact that Rollo's son is William. That is not a Viking name. And William is praised by a monk as a lover of peace and a lover and consoler of the poor and a defender of orphans and a protector of widows. Is that true? Well, those are lines that are written to commemorate his murder by the Count of Flanders.
这些载着英国战利品和俘虏的维京船只正驶向诺曼港口时，他一点也不感到惊讶。这正是他所预料的。然而，故事还有另一面，那就是随着时间的推移，这些人已经慢慢地——我敢说——法兰西化了。随着时间的推移，他们变得更加基督化了，这样说公平吗？还有法兰克化。所以他们被授予的头衔是鲁昂伯爵。你知道，那是一个拉丁化的头衔。同样，你可以从罗洛的儿子叫威廉这一点看出他们的语言也在发生变化。那不是一个维京名字。威廉被一个僧侣赞誉为和平的爱好者、穷人的爱护者和安慰者、孤儿的捍卫者以及寡妇的保护者。这是真的吗？嗯，这些台词是为了纪念他在与法兰德斯伯爵的会面中遇害而写的。
William had gone to meet the Count of Flanders under truce and as a good Christian who had sworn an oath not to take a sword, he had assumed that the Count of Flanders would do the same and poor old William ends up being cut down. So in a sense, he's proven himself more Christian than the Count of Flanders. And we mentioned Richard the fearless, this guy who looks like Odin, kind of wandering around and fighting the dead. His son is also called Richard and he becomes so admired for his piety that he is given the title Richard the good. And he's a great founder of monasteries, he's's great patron of churches. He has excellent
威廉在休战期间去见法兰德斯伯爵，作为一个发誓不拔剑的好基督徒，他以为法兰德斯伯爵也会这样做，结果可怜的威廉最终被砍倒了。从某种意义上说，他证明了自己比法兰德斯伯爵更具基督精神。我们提到了无所畏惧的理查，这个看起来像奥丁、四处游荡并与死者战斗的家伙。他的儿子也叫理查，他因虔诚而广受赞誉，以至于被授予了“好人理查”的称号。他是修道院的伟大建立者，也是教堂的伟大赞助人。他与
relations with the king of, let's call him the king of France by this point, you know, West Francia. This kind of realm that is evolving out of what had been the empire of Charlemagne and kind of becoming the kingdom of France. It won't be called France until much later, but I think we can call it France without too much risk of anachronism. And Richard the Good, he's a loyal ally of the French king, and I think he's kind of angling for a promotion. He's a bit bored of being the Count of Rouen. He started to call himself the Duke of Normandy, and he wants the French king and everyone else to kind of buy into this as well. And so you can see that the Viking and the Christian and the Frankish are all part of the mix. And because you have this Christian element, there is actually something
法兰克国王（此时我们可以称他为法兰克国王，你知道的，西法兰克）保持着极好的关系。这个王国从查理曼大帝的帝国演变而来，并逐渐成为法兰克王国。它直到很久以后才被称为法国，但我认为我们可以称其为法国，而不会冒太大时代错乱的风险。好人理查是法兰克国王的忠实盟友，我认为他一直在争取升迁。他对做鲁昂伯爵有点厌倦了。他开始自称为诺曼底公爵，并希望法兰克国王和其他所有人也接受这一点。因此你可以看到，维京元素、基督元素和法兰克元素都是这个混合体的一部分。正因为有了这个基督教元素，实际上还有一些
there for Athelred to play with. Right. Because could you not argue if you're looking, if you're him, you could say instead of just buying these people off year after year, or maybe trying to fight them, why don't I say to them, you know, I don't know, a bit like the Romans with the Germanic tribes. Why don't you say to them, guys, you know, why don't you just come and live here and you can police the coast for me. That's basically what Charles the Simple had done with the Normans. Well, I don't think he wants to do that, because you can see that Normandy hasn't turned out brilliantly. But you know, he doesn't
东西可供埃塞尔雷德利用。对吧。因为如果你站在他的角度来看，难道你不会争辩说，与其年复一年地贿赂这些人，或者试图与他们战斗，为什么我不对他们说，你知道的，有点像罗马人对待日耳曼部落那样？为什么不对他们说，伙计们，你知道的，你们为什么不直接搬到这里来，替我巡视海岸呢？这基本上就是简单王查理对诺曼人做的事。嗯，我认为他不想这么做，因为你可以看到诺曼底并没有发展得那么辉煌。但你知道，他
want that. So it's actually an object lesson in what to avoid. Right. And also there are, you know, there are lots of Danes in England who've been settled there since the previous century. And there is the suspicion that they are kind of helping out the Vikings when they carve a fifth column. A fifth column.
不想那样。所以这实际上是一个关于应该避免什么的生动教训。对吧。而且，你知道，英格兰有很多丹麦人，自上个世纪以来就在那里定居。并且人们怀疑他们在暗中帮助维京人，构成了第五纵队。第五纵队。
So I don't think he wants to do that. But obviously one of the things he can do is to say to the Viking warlords, as well as giving them money, he could say, you know, you could use this money to go off and, and found a Christian kingdom back in Scandinavia and the person that he, he particularly works on is the most sinister and formidable of all his opponents, and that is Olaf Trigvason. So the deal is he will give Olaf Trigvason, even by the standards of the Dengel, a massive amount of money. So he raises £16,000. I mean, that is an
所以我认为他不想那样。但显然他能做的事情之一，就是对维京军阀说，除了给他们钱，他还可以说，你知道，你可以用这些钱去斯堪的纳维亚建立一个基督教王国。而他特别针对的人是他所有对手中最阴险、最强大的一个，那就是奥拉夫·特里格瓦森（Olaf Tryggvason）。所以交易是这样的：他将给奥拉夫·特里格瓦森一大笔钱，即使按丹麦金的标准来看也是巨款。他筹集了16,000英镑。我的意思是，那是一个
obscene amount of money. But in return, Trigverson has to accept baptism at the hands of Athelstan, who will become his godfather. It's possible he has been baptized before either in the Sili Islands or in Denmark, but it is this great ceremony which is held in the heartlands of Wessex, which is the kind of the definitive entry of Olaf Trigvison into the Christian people. And this policy, Athelred's policy, his wheeze works brilliantly. So Trigvison, armed with his cash and baptized as a Christian, he becomes fired with the zeal of a true convert, he becomes convinced that Christ has personally chosen him to become King of the North Way and to bring his countrymen to baptism. And so he heads back home, kind of burning and looting and enslaving as he goes in the name of the Prince of Peace, and
天文数字般的巨额资金。但作为交换，特里格瓦森必须接受由Athelstan（译者注：此处或指代受洗见证人）施予的洗礼，后者将成为他的教父。他以前可能在锡利群岛或丹麦受洗过，但正是这场在威塞克斯腹地举行的盛大仪式，标志着奥拉夫·特里格瓦森正式步入基督教民众的行列。这项政策，埃塞尔雷德的政策，他的妙计取得了巨大的成功。于是特里格瓦森带着现金并以基督徒身份受洗后，燃起了真正皈依者的狂热，他坚信基督亲自挑选他成为挪威之王，并引导他的同胞接受洗礼。于是他带着一路上的焚烧、掠夺和奴役返回故乡，以和平王子的名义，而
Athelred, back in England, can breathe an enormous sigh of relief. He can start to look on Olaf Trigvason almost as an ally because when Olaf goes back to Norway, he does so accompanied by an English bishop and when he arrives in Norway, he's got all this money behind him so he can hire large, large numbers of followers who were attracted as well by the fame of his name. And he very rapidly topples the local strongman. The strongman runs away, ends up hiding in a pigsty and there he is decapitated by his own thrall. So it is, ha ha ha ha. That is the kind of fate that any great conqueror would wish on his rival. And Ollef Trigvison, he sets about trying to convert Norway to Christianity.
远在英格兰的埃塞尔雷德则可以长舒一口气。他几乎可以把奥拉夫·特里格瓦森视为盟友，因为当奥拉夫返回挪威时，有一位英国主教随行，当他抵达挪威时，他手里有这么多钱，因此可以雇用大量追随者，这些人也被他的名声所吸引。他非常迅速地推翻了当地的强权。那个强权落荒而逃，最终躲在一个猪圈里，在那里被他自己的家奴斩首。所以，哈哈哈哈。这就是任何伟大的征服者都希望降临在他竞争对手身上的命运。而奥拉夫·特里格瓦森，他开始着手试图让挪威皈依基督教。
So he builds the first church in Norway, he founds Trondheim and what he is doing, he's not just behaving as a Christian, but specifically as a Christian king. Right. Well, we'll get into this a little bit more when we do our episodes about Norway and about Harald Hardrada later on and about how much, you know, how much is he motivated as you said, by wanting to copy the Prince of Peace and how much is he really thinking Christianity is the prestige religion. It means status, it means power, it means kingship, it means authority.
于是他在挪威建造了第一座教堂，建立了特隆赫姆，他所做的不仅是表现得像个基督徒，而是明确地表现得像个基督教国王。好吧，当我们以后做关于挪威、关于哈拉尔·哈德拉达（Harald Hardrada）的节目时，我们会更深入地探讨这一点——他究竟有多少动机，正如你所说的那样，是出于想要效仿和平王子，又有多少是他真的认为基督教是一种享有声望的宗教。它意味着地位，意味着权力，意味着王权，意味着权威。
Yeah. And you know, that's what I'm buying into. But just to go back to England. So there are Vikings left in English waters, aren't there? Because Ethelred has actually bought a large part of Olaf's army and possibly some of his fleet. So there are probably thousands of troops of Danes basically hanging around and we will come to what happens to them. But also I know this is absolute Tom Holland bingo.
是的。你知道，这就是我所接受的。但回到英格兰。所以英格兰水域里还留着维京人，对吧？因为埃塞尔雷德实际上买下了奥拉夫军队的大部分人马，可能还有他的一些舰队。所以可能还有数千名丹麦军队在附近闲逛，我们接下来会讨论他们的下落。而且我也知道这绝对是汤姆·霍兰德式的宾果游戏。
So you know, yeah, let's go for it. So enjoy yourself. The millennium is coming and people at this point, so at the end of the 10th century, people at this point start to think, well, when the year 1000, when we get to the year 1000, that probably be the end of the world, so we should start making our dispositions accordingly. I'm not sure they quite think that, and it's further complicated by the fact that actually you're not allowed under the rulings of the Church Fathers to speculate. You're not allowed.
所以你知道，好吧，我们开始吧。好好享受吧。千禧年即将来临，此时的人们——也就是10th世纪末期，这个时候的人们开始想，嗯，当公元1000年到来时，当我们到达公元1000年时，那可能就是世界的尽头，所以我们应该开始做相应的准备。我不确定他们是否真的这么想，而且情况更加复杂，因为实际上根据教父们的规矩，你是不被允许去进行这种推测的。你不被允许。
You can sense, I think, in many things that English churchmen are writing, that there is a sense that the millennial anniversary of themen are writing, that there is a sense that the millennial anniversary of the birth of Christ, that something is kind of looming. So back in 971, the Archbishop of York had warned in very stern tones, so veiled by secrecy is the end of days that no one in the entire world, no matter how holy, nor even anyone in heaven except the Lord alone has ever known when it will come. So that's the standard Christian teaching. You know, don't speculate. But the bishop then he can't leave it alone. And so he ends his sermon by declaring all the signs and forewarnings that our Lord told us would herald doomsday have come to pass. So basically,
我想你从英国神职人员撰写的许多文章中可以感觉到，有一种预感，即基督诞生的千禧周年纪念日，有什么事情正在逼近。早在971年，约克大主教就用严厉的语气警告过：末日是如此地被严密保守，以至于全世界没有一个人，无论他多么神圣，甚至连天堂里除了主之外的任何人，都从未知道它何时会到来。这就是标准的基督教教义。你知道，不要去猜测。但这位主教随后还是忍不住。于是他在布道结束时宣布：我们主告诉我们预示世界末日的所有迹象和预兆都已经应验了。所以基本上，
don't speculate. Oh my God, it's going to happen. That's essentially where he's at. And there's actually, there's a lot of this, isn't there in the final decades of the century and, you know, whether or not churchmen believe it, it's kind of irrelevant because the person who definitely seems to have believed it, who maybe thinks, you know, I've actually been appointed by, by fate, by, by God, to be the person who's in charge at this crucial moment in human history and the history of the universe is Ethelred himself. Right. And the idea that Ethelred is some kind of wuss, that in a way he is less prone to violence than say a Viking chieftain, couldn't be more wrong. Actually he's more than capable when he gets his act together and has the opportunity to kind of focus on external enemies,
不要去猜测。天哪，这就要发生了。这基本上就是他的态度。而且实际上，这个世纪的最后几十年里有很多这样的言论，你知道的，不管神职人员是否相信，这其实并不重要，因为那个绝对似乎相信这一点的人——他可能认为，你知道，我实际上是被命运、被上帝任命为在这个人类历史和宇宙历史的关键时刻负责的人——正是埃塞尔雷德本人。对吧。认为埃塞尔雷德是个软蛋，认为他在某种程度上比维京首领更不容易诉诸暴力的想法，是大错特错的。实际上，当他振作起来并有机会专注于外部敌人时，他完全有能力
to feel that going and attacking them is absolutely God's will and that this is the best way to prepare England for the millennial challenges or opportunities that may be approaching. So in the year 1000 itself, he leads an expedition deep into Scotland ravaging away, just like a Viking might. And in the same year, he actually sends an expedition across the channel to launch a raid on Normandy. And later Norman sources will say that this was beaten off, but I'm not convinced by that because it certainly seems to have served Ethelred's purposes, which is essentially to intimidate the Count of Rouen or the Duke of Normandy, whatever
觉得去攻击他们绝对是上帝的意志，这是为英格兰迎接可能临近的千禧年挑战或机遇做好准备的最佳方式。因此，在公元1000年当年，他率领远征军深入苏格兰大肆掠夺，就像一个维京人那样。同年，他还派出一支远征队渡过海峡对诺曼底发动突袭。后来的诺曼文献会说这被击退了，但我对此表示怀疑，因为它肯定达到了埃塞尔雷德的目的，本质上是恐吓鲁昂伯爵或诺曼底公爵——无论
you want to call him, into behaving, into, into not being so welcoming to the pirates who've been praying on England. And the most striking evidence for this comes early in 1002, when Richard the Good, the Duke of Normandy agrees to marry his sister, Emma, to Ethelred. And it is recorded in the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle. Then in the spring, the lady, Richard's daughter, came to this land and Emma on her arrival is given an English name, so Alf Giffo. We don't know how she felt about that, but we'll continue to call her Emma.
你想怎么称呼他——让他老实点，不要对那些一直袭扰英格兰的海盗那么热情欢迎。这方面最突出的证据出现在1002年初，诺曼底公爵好人理查同意将他的妹妹埃玛（Emma）嫁给埃塞尔雷德。盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史记载了这件事：然后在春天，这位女士，理查的女儿来到了这片土地，埃玛一到达就被赋予了一个英文名字——阿尔夫吉弗（Alf Giffo）。我们不知道她对此作何感想，但我们将继续叫她埃玛。
And she is anointed as queen. And Ethelred is the first English king to marry a foreign bride since the father of Alfred the Great, and it is a marker of his increasingly proactive and assertive exercise of policy. And the English people looking at Atherred, looking at the sister of the Duke of Normandy, Emma, sat beside him, they could start to feel that perhaps the worst is over. That actually perhaps what the millennium is bringing is the promise of a kind of universal and eternal age of peace and that the wheat field of England's kingdom, and I use that
并且她被涂抹圣油加冕为王后。埃塞尔雷德是自阿尔弗雷德大帝的父亲以来第一位迎娶外国新娘的英格兰国王，这标志着他日益积极和自信的政策实施。英国人民看着埃塞尔雷德，看着坐在他身边的诺曼底公爵的妹妹埃玛，他们开始觉得也许最糟糕的时刻已经过去。也许千禧年带来的是一种普遍而永恒的和平时代的承诺，英格兰王国的麦田——我刻意使用了
metaphor pointedly, at last it's been secured against all the trampling of Viking feet and bloody flames and blight and storms and ruin, that at last the harvest time for England is come. Well, that sounds lovely. Now we'll come back to Emma in this series because she is a massive, massively interesting and important figure. It's a shame we don't actually know more about her in her life because she's one of those women whose story kind of blazes across medieval history. However, I enjoyed your wheat field metaphor. Did you? You picked that up? I did pick that up and I'm thinking I can see where you're going with it and I can see that Ethelred is also somebody who enjoys a wheat field metaphor because he is going to develop this metaphor himself in an excitingly bloody way.
这个隐喻——终于免受了维京人脚步的践踏、血腥的烈火、枯萎、风暴和毁灭的侵扰，英格兰的收获季节终于到来了。嗯，听起来真不错。现在我们在这个系列中会再次提到埃玛，因为她是一个非常、非常有趣且重要的人物。真遗憾，我们对她生平的了解其实并不多，因为她是那种在欧洲中世纪历史上大放异彩的女性。不过，我喜欢你的麦田隐喻。是吗？你注意到了？我确实注意到了，而且我想我能看出你要表达的方向，我也看出埃塞尔雷德也是一个喜欢麦田隐喻的人，因为他将以一种令人兴奋的血腥方式亲自阐述这个隐喻。
So the wheat field, I think to any devout Christian listening to that would immediately have reminded them of Christ's words as recorded in the New Testament. So, Ethered undoubtedly is looking to the words of Christ for guidance how he should rule his king. Christ had said, He who sows the good seed is the Son of Man. The field is the world and the good seed means the sons of the kingdom. The weeds are the sons of the evil one and the enemy who sowed them is the devil. The harvest is the close of the age and the reapers are angels. Just as the weeds are gathered and burned with fire, so will it be at the close of the age. And so if it is the close of the age, if this is what the millennium portends, then does
所以，麦田，我认为任何听到这一点的虔诚基督徒都会立刻联想到新约中记载的基督的话语。因此，埃塞尔雷德无疑是在寻求基督的话语来指导他如何统治他的王国。基督曾说：那撒好种的是人子，田地就是世界，好种就是天国之子，稗子就是恶者之子，撒稗子的仇敌就是魔鬼，收割的时候就是世界的末了，收割的人就是天使。将稗子薅出来用火焚烧，世界的末了也是这样。因此，如果是世界的末了，如果这就是千禧年所预示的，那么这
that mean that it is time to gather the weeds and consign them to flames? Get rid. Yeah. And so who might these weeds be? Well, so Trigverson and his men have gone, but there are lots of other Northmen or Danes. So the English tend to call all the Northmen Danes as a collective and These people are living openly in the towns of England and many of these are recent arrivals Lots of them claiming to be merchants
是否意味着是时候收集稗子并将它们付诸烈火了？除掉它们。是的。那么这些稗子可能是谁呢？嗯，特里格瓦森和他的手下已经走了，但还有很多其他的北方人或丹麦人。所以英国人倾向于把所有的北方人都统称为丹麦人，而这些人公开住在英格兰的城镇里，其中许多人是新近到达的，许多人声称自己是商人
But you know, can you be sure others are mercenaries as you said who've been employed by a thread himself and they keep rebelling Don't they so I had a look they rebel rebelled in 997, 999, the year 1000. I mean, they are very disputatious and difficult because they are thugs, they're armed men. Right. And so how can Aetherred know what atrocities and rebellions they might not be plotting? And more than that, you know, they're a fifth column. What if Viking Raiders come back from overseas? Right. You know, These are a standing danger. And so it is that Ethelred decides on a fateful millennially tinged policy. So to quote him, his own words, a decree was sent out by me with the counsel of my leading men and magnates to the effect
但是，你知道，你能确定吗？其他人则是雇佣兵，正如你所说，是被埃塞尔雷德本人雇用的，而且他们不断叛乱，对吧？所以我查了一下，他们在997年、999年、公元1000年都叛乱过。我的意思是，他们非常好斗且难以对付，因为他们是暴徒，是武装人员。对吧。那么埃塞尔雷德怎么能知道他们可能在密谋什么暴行和叛乱呢？不仅如此，你知道，他们是第五纵队。如果维京海盗从海外卷土重来呢？对吧。你知道，这些人是一个持续存在的危险。因此，埃塞尔雷德决定采取一项宿命般的、带有千禧年色彩的政策。用他自己的话说，由我和我的主要谋士及贵族商议，颁布了一道法令
that all the Danes who had sprung up in the island, sprouting like weeds among the wheat. So that absolutely nails it. This, you know, Ethelred has that biblical verse in mind, were to be destroyed by a most just extermination. And this decree was to be put into effect even as far as death. So this is what sets the scene for the massacre of St. Bryce's day, which is on the 13th of November, the 1002. I mean, the amazing thing about it, I guess, is that in a more disorganized state, it would not have been possible, but precisely because England is centralized, well-run, a well-oiled machine, Ethelred can send out his orders across the kingdom.
：“所有在这个岛屿上崛起、像麦田里的稗子一样萌芽的丹麦人，都要通过一场最正义的灭绝来消灭。”这真是说到了点子上。这，你知道的，埃塞尔雷德心里记着那段圣经经文，这一法令将付诸实施，直至处死。这就是圣布莱斯日大屠杀的背景，时间是1002年11月13日。我的意思是，关于这件事最令人惊奇的地方，我想，如果是在一个更加无序的国家，这是不可能做到的，但恰恰因为英格兰是一个中央集权、运转良好、润滑流畅的机器，埃塞尔雷德才能将他的命令下达到整个王国。
We can't be sure how many people are killed, but to people across the kingdom and to say on such and such a day, you round up the Danes and kill them all. Well, what do you think, Tom? I mean, I think it's clear that the apparatus of the English state, very effective at raising taxes is also very effective at organizing a pogrom. And there is undoubtedly a lot of slaughter. I mean, I think it's improbable that all the Danes in England are killed just because there
我们无法确定有多少人被杀死，但却是向整个王国的人下达指令，在某某日子把丹麦人统统抓起来杀光。嗯，你觉得呢，汤姆？我的意思是，我认为很明显，擅长征税的英国国家机器在组织一场大屠杀时也同样高效。毫无疑问，这里有大量的屠杀。我的意思是，我认为英格兰所有的丹麦人都被杀掉是不太可能的，仅仅因为
are so many of them and the process of identifying who exactly is a Dane is also complex. But there's no question that those who are targeted for elimination are massacred with extreme prejudice and we actually have archaeological evidence for this so we're told that in Oxford. Dane's are incinerated as they huddled together for protection and church. I need two thousand and eight archaeologists were excavating in the grounds of St. John's College in Oxford. I found the skeletons of thirty seven young men and children who presumably were victims of this particular massacre. And it's likely hundreds perished. And precisely because Ethelred's language is so overtly apocalyptic,
他们的数量太多了，而且要确切辨别谁是丹麦人的过程也很复杂。但毫无疑问，那些成为清除目标的人遭到了极端的残酷屠杀，我们实际上有这方面的考古证据——据说在牛津，丹麦人在教堂里挤作一团寻求庇护时被活活烧死。2008年，考古学家在牛津圣约翰学院的土地上进行发掘时，发现了37名年轻男子和儿童的骨骼，他们推测正是这次大屠杀的受害者。数百人丧生是很有可能的。而且正是因为埃塞尔雷德的语言带有如此明显的末日色彩，
this bloodshed must have seemed to everyone in England kind of freighted with ominous meaning. The sense that, you know, if these are the weeds who've been planted by the devil, then Ethelred and the English must be engaged in the battle with satanic powers. And whether that's entirely reassurance, of course, I mean, the sense that that that Antichrist or whoever may be kind of lurking on the orders, you know, that is something to worry about, but there is also another more pressing, less supernatural cause of worry, which is that the Danes back in Denmark, they have a king and what's he going to make of it?
这场流血事件在英格兰所有人看来，一定都充满了不祥的意味。那种感觉，你知道的，如果这些是魔鬼种下的稗子，那么埃塞尔雷德和英国人一定是在与撒旦势力进行战争。这是否完全能让人安心，当然了，我的意思是，那种反基督者或其他什么东西可能潜伏在暗处的感觉，你知道，那是令人担忧的事情，但同时还有另一个更加紧迫、不那么超自然的担忧原因，那就是丹麦的丹麦人有一个国王，他会对此作何感想？
And there is a report, it's very late, so not entirely reliable, but the fact that it comes to be reported, I think, points to the risk that Aethelred has taken. And this report is that one of the women who were killed in the massacre was a woman called Gunhilde, and that she was the sister of the King of Denmark. And how is this going to go down across the waters of the North Sea? Well, Tom, do you want to know what a bestselling recent history of this period for younger readers makes of this moment? So sometimes historians are criticized for not using enough imagination.
而且有一则报告，时间非常靠后，所以不完全可靠，但它被报道出来这件事，我认为指出了埃塞尔雷德所冒的风险。这则报告说，大屠杀中被杀害的女性之一是一个名叫冈希尔德（Gunhild）的女人，她是丹麦国王的妹妹。这在北海对岸会引发怎样的轩然大波呢？好了，汤姆，你想知道这时期的一本面向年轻读者的畅销最新历史书是如何看待这一时刻的吗？有时历史学家会因为缺乏想象力而受到批评。
And I don't think you could say this about this passage. Let's hear it. So this is from your book for children on the Vikings. As darkness fell over the Thames, a ship pulled away from an old wooden jetty. Huddle the board wrapped in their cloaks was a group of young Danish men who had managed to escape the flashing knives. For days they sailed east, chilled by the gales and soaked by the waves, grief and shock written all over their faces. Only when they glimpsed the dunes of the Danish coast did they breathe a sigh of relief. When they stood there in the hall of the King, panting out their dreadful story, he said
我不认为你可以这样评价这段文字。让我们听听。这是你写的儿童维京人读物中的内容：“当黑暗降临泰晤士报（泰晤士河），一艘船缓缓驶离古老的木质码头。蜷缩在船上、裹着斗篷的是一群年轻的丹麦男子，他们侥幸逃脱了闪闪发光的匕首。他们向东航行了数日，被狂风冻得瑟瑟发抖，被海浪浸透，悲伤和震惊写在每个人的脸上。直到瞥见丹麦海岸的沙丘，他们才长舒了一口气。当他们站在国王的大厅里，气喘吁吁地讲述着他们可怕的故事时，国王什么也没说。
nothing. But in his cold blue eyes, there was only death. The next morning the word went out, all men must make ready. When spring came, the king was sailing west. Srain Forkbeard would have his revenge. And this time, there would be no quarter. Cold blue eyes. Terrifying. Definitely had them. So in our next episode, those cold blue eyes will be fixed on England with consequences that we will be exploring.
但在他冰冷的蓝眼睛里，只有死亡。第二天清晨，消息传出，所有人必须做好准备。当春天来临时，国王正向西航行。叉须斯韦恩（Sweyn Forkbeard）将复仇。这一次，将不留活口。”冰冷的蓝眼睛。太可怕了。绝对有这种眼神。所以在我们的下一集里，那些冰冷的蓝眼睛将锁定英格兰，其后果将是我们所要探讨的。
And if you want to hear that and indeed the rest of this series, all four episodes, you will get them if you are already a member of the Restless History Club. And if you're not, you can go to therestlesshistory.com and sign up there. Amazing. So next time Svein Fortbeard has his revenge. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想听那一集以及本系列的其余部分，全部四集，如果你已经是“不安分历史俱乐部”（Restless History Club）的会员，你就可以收听到。如果你还不是，你可以前往 therestlesshistory.com 在那里注册。太棒了。那么下一次，叉须斯韦恩将复仇。再见。再见。再见。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。